what is the purpose of these questions
trying to establish a baseline for what
fidelity hey everybody is Charlie this
is gonna be my West world finale video
how about that post credit scene just
remember that time does not move in a
linear fashion on this show they jump
around all over the place
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
it yet I'll probably do another separate
video about the post credit scene in
season 3 because the producers have
talked about what their plan is for
future seasons it was renewed for season
3 a little while ago so we will be
getting that but it might not happen
next year so if you're finding me for
the first time
be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos but here we go top 10 WTF and
Easter eggs as we go along starting with
number 10 Delores and Bernard inside
what we know now as the real world it
seems like all these scenes that we've
been watching all season long have
actually been happening at the end of
the season in the real world at Arnold's
house in China as Dolores has been
bringing him back after they escaped the
park the really interesting thing about
this though is that they say that she's
tried this eleven thousand nine hundred
and twenty seven times now that might
also include all the versions that she
tried when she originally tried to do
this the first time because remember she
created the first version of Bernard
then he went on to work with Ford in the
park we eventually found out that he was
a host during season one then when she
escaped the park at the end of the
season she recreated him so that 11,000
number probably includes extra attempts
when she brought him back because she
implies that she changed him just a
little bit more to because she tells
that big story about why it was so
important that she changed aspects of
Arnold's personality because every
single loop brought him back to the same
point where he wanted to kill himself
that also sort of syncs up with the
moment with the man in black at the end
- like how his loop always ends with a
specific defining moment also really
cool parallel for the James del Ozark
that we would always see end with this
moment of him rejecting Logan the whole
idea being that regular people are
fundamentally flawed and they will
always end up in the same place no
matter what you change about them or
which different decisions they make
they'll always find themselves at the
same outcome so I love the way that
they're implying that the message of the
series is that humans bad
host good number 9 you see all the
groups start to converge for the forge
at the beginning of the episode you have
Charlotte's group you have the ghost
nation group you have the man in black
who's now met up with Dolores love that
pair together can't wait to see their
reunion next season she also says that
she saw Emily's body so I know that
creates a lot of questions about Emily
popping up during that post-credit scene
because once a simulation what's real
they're just messing with your minds I'm
sure the show runners are laughing at
themselves while everybody tries to
figure it out but I do love the way that
Dolores pocketed Teddy's memory ball
they were pretty clear about what
happened with Teddy's character but
number 8 Maeve's amazing escape so I
love that Hector is rallying sizemore in
their group I tried to save her but
easier bursts of the doors with those
Bulls that was actually in the Super
Bowl trailer so they actually put
footage from the finale in one of the
trailers a long time ago but here's
where it gets a little confusing with
the timeline they used Bernard is the
anchor so you're always viewing
different timelines from his perspective
like he'll sit there and flash forward
into the future or flash back into the
past so number seven we get Bernard at
the forge with the man in black and
Dolores they enter after he tries to
kill Dolores I love that totally
reminded me of infinity war you should
have aimed for the head we learned that
they're about 4 million people every
person that has ever entered the park
and this sort of like this long gambit
Charlotte says well if people find out
about it but it works will they really
care so you don't really know what the
timeline for Delos is on this like how
long are they gonna keep working on this
before they actually start to reveal it
to people and try to sell it as new
technology I think by the time everybody
saw that giant underground cooling
reservoir you sort of understood the
lake at the beginning of the season all
the bodies sitting there because as they
open the gateway they all start falling
down into the valley but then the valley
fills with water so that's how the hosts
all wind up washed up on the shore even
though it was a little confusing it was
fun to see them jump backwards and
forwards in time from Bernards
perspective while they're grilling him
obviously you know that this is secretly
Dolores after the episode but you still
think that it's Charlotte's group so
they did this thing in the episode where
they show you a twist then they show you
how they got to that twist with a
flashback but we finally get to see
inside the forge so I'm just calling
this the valley beyond but technically
the valley beyond is like the secret sub
area that Barnard created for the host
to save themselves so you have the
mainframe that stores all the people the
valley beyond is just a separate
instance within that that they later
beam out at the end of the season I'll
talk about that too there was a little
open-ended about what happened to all
the host data when they beamed it away
but it was fun walking through all the
different instances of James de luces
versions like you basically get the
explainer from the Logan AI which was
another mind blow like oh my god this is
Logan no wait it's not Logan it's just
an AI wearing Logan's skin built from
memories from James doses mind but it's
basically controlling the entire forge
trying to recreate a faithful version of
James Della's that's the whole reason
that it exists so we think the other
important reason why they showed you
James Delos was to remind you back from
Episode four when we were inside the
lost bunker about how he kept going
crazy he kept going through the same
loop even though we got a little bit
better each time the AI tells us that it
created 18 million different iterations
of his character but he was able to boil
down the essence of each person to this
book which became that epic library I
actually thought that that was a real
library when I was watching the trail
like okay maybe this just exists inside
the forge for people to enjoy nope
these are all just digital
representations of each person's life
every single one of the four million
people so number six the AI tells us
that Bernard has come to the forge many
many times before to create this special
sub instance called the valley beyond
but also to allow the host to read from
the books to learn about people to
better enable them to survive in the
real world benbarnes did a fantastic job
playing the different versions of Logan
to the heartbreaking scene of watching
him be rejected by his father and they
kept saying that James jell-o's would
come back to that no matter how they
changed his code and think about it this
way if you wonder whether or not Logan
will come back in future seasons there
was this really important line that
Dolores had at the end where she said
you're never dead as long as there's
someone that remembers you or some
version of that that wasn't the exact
line but it's implied that this version
of Logan was pulled from James Dallas's
memory so if the man in black is still
alive in the real
and he remembers Logan that Logan can
still come back but number five
Sizemore's last stand he sacrifices
himself for maybe it's a great scene
it's my bloody speech it's the same
speech that Hector would give back
during season one when he would ride
into Sweetwater to rob the mariposa I
didn't see his body at the end of the
episode so it's implied that he might be
dead I'm hoping there's a chance that
he's on that beach somewhere and I just
didn't spot him and they'll heal him in
he'll return but it's a very effective
Redemption if you didn't feel like he
earned a measure of redemption before
this is definitely it number four the
Gateway to the valley beyond this seemed
like it was right out of a Star Trek
episode the weird thing about it is they
show it to you from the hosts
perspective first then they let you know
that only the host can see it so that's
why for a brief second you're left
wondering whether or not this device has
created a rift in space-time is this
like a tear in the fabric of reality
what's going on the simple explanation
is is it it's just a supercharged
version of these devices that beam their
consciousness inside the matrix but like
I said that explains how all the bodies
can wind up washed up on the shore
because that area flooded but the host
can survive you get that really great
battle scene where Maeve saves her
daughter I love the look on her face
still she's smiling as she walks through
the Gateway it became pretty clear about
halfway through that battle what was
gonna happen
she does have God mode but she can only
control hosts that haven't awakened so
her abilities don't affect Hector
armistice or akicha
or any of the other people that have
already come to consciousness so if you
wonder why armistice and some of these
people are still trying to take down
these rogue hosts is because they're
conscious they can't be controlled by
other hosts number three though this is
where it really starts to get fun
Bernard's final choice in the secret
Charlotte this was so much fun
Tessa Thompson has been kind of weird
this season I actually like the way they
wrote her a little bit more during
season one she was just a bit more
blanket evil of this season there was a
little less nuance to her performance
until she became the Dolores version of
Charlotte so watching Tessa Thompson do
a version of Dolores acting like
Charlotte was a lot of fun it reminds
you that thor ragnarok scene where you
have loki pretending to be odin but it's
Anthony Hopkins in real life pretending
to be Loki pretending to be Odin so it's
another version of a dude playing a dude
pretending to be another dude
I think they did a good job of
explaining Ford's involvement and all of
this secret planning that Barnard did to
pull off the Charlotte twist they
explained that when he was still with LC
in last week's episode he erased the
actual Ford code from him so like the
special version of Ford was deleted this
version of Ford was just something that
he conjured up from his memories and
imagined it helping him which is why at
the end of the season he's like oh my
god I have all this stuff in my brain I
have to scramble it so that Delos can't
use it against me
number two Dolores escapes the park and
recreates Bernard I also love the Stubbs
scene to where he clearly implies he
knows that she's a host he might not
know that it's Dolores he also makes a
bunch of jokes and turns of phrase about
being a host himself he references
himself talking about programming so
just to be clear Stubbs is probably a
human he's just likening himself to a
host because he thinks that he's talking
to a host pretending to be Charlotte the
really important thing though is that
you see them riding away she looks in
her purse she has several memory balls
one of them we know is Bernards but we
don't know who the others belong to I'll
do another post credit scene video
tomorrow and talk about season three
because I think those are some of the
bigger characters you find out that
she's wearing the black dress from
episode one which was like a 30 years
ago flashback so there was a lot of
repeating motifs and visual imagery
lines of dialogue that go back you woke
me from a dream this isn't a dream this
is a nightmare but the really important
thing to remember is is that when she
tells him what's going on and he's like
I can't allow this to continue
she doesn't deny anything and says oh
yes we'll probably fight we'll probably
die but our kind will live on so it's
almost like they're teasing some huge
epic battle between the two of them in
season 3 like what the hell kind of a
bombshell is that to drop like oh yeah
we're definitely going to be warring
with each other for the future of this
series but at the end of the series she
beams all the host data from the valley
beyond to somewhere secret what I think
is going on is that that's just gonna be
some private server
well they'll continue to exist so the
like when the texts find Maeve on the
beach and they tell her like hey can you
fix everything they look at her body
like they're gonna fix Maeve Maeve his
daughter will still be alive they're
somewhere in the world Teddy will still
be alive in there somewhere but it'll be
stored on
light or somewhere that you just can't
get to in a really easy way so they'll
continue to exist but it will be
somewhere that anybody can find so it'll
be interesting to see if they bring
those characters back in season three
but number one we got to talk about that
man in black post-credit scene so what
happens is is earlier in the episode
when [ __ ] is still going down he crawls
up you know with a piece of his hand
missing makes his way down into the
forge and then we don't see what happens
to him we just see him entering the
lower basement of the forge and seeing
an apparition of his daughter or a
version of her that calls him William so
I'm thinking that this probably isn't
his daughter and very clearly they're
trying to mess with you so I think that
his daughter is really dead in real life
this version of his daughter is just
like the AI built to look like Logan
that was just wearing Logan's skin
trying to create a version of Delos that
would work in the real world but they're
really ambiguous about when this is
happening is this happening right after
the end of the season is this happening
many years into the future because he
implies that he doesn't know what time
it is and she says that they've been at
this for a long long time longer than
they thought possible so it's probably
been years but that doesn't necessarily
mean that the version of the man in
black that we've been saying all season
long you know questioning his reality is
actually been a host this whole time
even Ford said that the human backups
would never exist in the real world but
just post all your man and black
post-credit scene theories in the
comments below
when is this happening and who is this
version of the man in black on the beach
here but while you wait for everything
click here to watch Tom Holland spoil
the title of spider-man 2 and click here
for all my other Westworld videos thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]